Okay guys, we're gonna admit what our favorite pasta dishes on three ready. One, two, three. You'll see me off right now. Welcome to Smart List. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
好吧，伙们，我们要在三声准备后承认我们最喜欢的意面菜肴是什么。一，二，三。你现在就可以把我赶出去了。欢迎收看“聪明笨蛋”（SmartLess）。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. You seem so stressed out. Why are you so stressed out, Jay? I'm not. I'm really, I don't know why I'm tired today. No one wants to hear about it, though. This is probably not great. Why are you afraid of the golf start? It's just too much golf. You're right. Nobody does want to hear that. I just asked you if you were, why you were tired. I did have an early, an early round. I shot 77 yesterday. Well, but I just asked you if you were why you were tired. I did have an early an early round
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。你看起来压力好大。杰伊，你为什么压力这么大？我没有。我真的，我不知道为什么我今天这么累。不过没人想听这个。这可能不太妙。你为什么害怕高尔夫开局？高尔夫打太多了。你说得对。确实没人想听那个。我刚才只是问你是不是，为什么觉得累。我确实起得很早，打了一场早场。我昨天打出了77杆。好吧，但我刚才只是问你是不是，为什么觉得累。我确实起得很早，打了一场早场
I shot 77 yesterday. Well, I know you don't care and you don't want to hear about it But I'm very proud of it. I'm happy for you because you have the last couple weeks And I can say this now that you've shot you had a good round yesterday. You've had It's been unlike you and you've had some some mediocre rounds and I know you've been upset and you've had a few And you've had some some mediocre rounds and I know you've been upset and you've had a few grumpy or the usual days. Thank you for seeing me and hearing me. So I see you. Here's what the number 77 engulf means to me. That sounds really high. Well, um, the the the the level par normal is 70 or 72. Yeah. Okay. So that's it. Did every night watching Lord of the Rings. Okay. Moving on. I'll tell you this. Speaking of Lord of the Rings, are you guys being held hostage somewhere?
我昨天打出了77杆。好吧，我知道你不在乎，也不想听，但我为此感到非常骄傲。我为你高兴，因为你过去这几周……现在你可以这么说了，因为你昨天打得不错。你最近表现有点反常，打出了几个平庸的杆数，我知道你一直很不高兴，而且有那么几天……你有些日子比较暴躁或者和平时不太一样。谢谢你注意到我，理解我。所以我懂你。高尔夫里的77杆对我来说意味着什么。听起来分很高啊。嗯，标准杆通常是70杆或72杆。对。好吧，那就这样。每天晚上看《指环王》。好吧，接着说。我跟你说个事，说到《指环王》，你们是被什么人绑架了吗？
What's going on? I've never seen any of them, but I'll bet. Oh my God. They're so very good. Speaking of Lord of the Rings, I, uh, Amanda and I have our anniversary coming up. I can say this because she won't, well, no, she isn't listening to these. I have it in my calendar. And you're anniversary. Amanda does not listen. She does not listen. So we have it coming up in a month or so
怎么回事？我一部都没看过，但我敢打赌。噢天哪。它们真的非常棒。说到《指环王》，我，呃，我和阿曼达的结婚纪念日快到了。我可以这么说，因为她不会，呃，不对，她不听这个。我的日历上有记录。而你们的纪念日。阿曼达不听这个。她不听。所以我们大概在一个月后就要迎来了
and I thought about getting her a ring, this ring from this jeweler that she likes. How many years? I haven't bought her any jewelry in a long, long time and so this is, and I usually don't do it unless it's a pre-approved by her because anytime I try to, like, go rogue, I get slammed. Jay, I got to try to do it. Dude, enough with all the hot romance. It sounds so incredible. So, uh, so, I have somebody if you want somebody. No, no, I got that. He's got that person who's approved by a man. You might know who he is. This is a pre-approved person.
我想给她买个戒指，就是她喜欢的那家珠宝店的戒指。多少年了？我好久好久没给她买过珠宝了，所以这次，而且我通常不会自己拿主意，除非经过她事先批准，因为每次只要我想自己“独断专行”，就会挨批。杰伊，我得试着去做这件事。老兄，别再秀什么火热的浪漫了。听起来太不可思议了。所以，呃，所以，如果你需要有人，我倒认识这么个人。不，不，我有了。他有那个经过阿曼达批准的人。你可能知道他是谁。这是一个经过事先批准的人。
I know the person. But we share a calendar. We share a calendar, Amanda and I. And so I had to put a reminder of my calendar to go to this jeweler today. And because I'm going to get her a ring, I put as the prompt of the calendar as just Lord. Lord of the rings for Lord of the rings.
我认识这个人。但我们共用一个日历。我和阿曼达共用一个日历。所以我不得不在日历上设置一个提醒，今天要去这家珠宝店。因为我要给她买个戒指，我在日历的事由里只写了“Lord”。为了“Lord of the rings”（指环王）写了“Lord”。
Now our assistant shares a calendar to with us. And I'm waiting for her to say, where have you found to worship on Tuesday? Why are you worshiping on Tuesday? But I couldn't come up with a better prompt in the calendar. That's my Lord of the rings. Is that what Lord meant? Is Lord of the Ring? Yeah, Lord of the Ring. So I would remember, oh, go get that ring today. Right. And did you get it? I don't know.
现在我们的助理也能看到我们共用的日历。我在等她问：“你周二要去哪里做礼拜？你为什么要在周二做礼拜？”但我实在想不出日历上更好的提示了。那就是我的“Lord of the rings”。“Lord”是那个意思吗？对，指环王。所以我才能记住，哦，今天去把那个戒指拿了。对。那你拿到了吗？我不知道。
Not yet. It's after this. I gotta be honest. Not a great story. It's a long story, but I will say this. That's my specialty, bro. That it begs a lot of questions from the other two people with whom you share a calendar, which I think is a mistake.
还没。录完这个再去。老实说，这不是个好故事。说来话长，但我得说：这正是我的专长，老兄。这会引起和你共用日历另外两个人的很多疑问，我觉得这是一个错误。
A, B, I don't have a good secret. I don't have a good secret, so you have an assistant. And if a man has a question about your calendar, you can say, hey, can you, how's he look like on this day? Yeah. B. But C, by putting Lord, it's begging someone to go away. So you say what's going on?
第一，第二，我没有不可告人的秘密。我没有秘密，所以你有助理。如果阿曼达对你的日历有疑问，你可以说，嘿，能帮我看看我那天看起来怎么样吗？对。第二。但是第三，加上“Lord”这个词，简直是在引诱别人追问到底是怎么回事。所以你会问怎么了？
What's going on? And what you should have done is done something like golf lesson. Yeah, or some stupid fucking thing like that. But no, you didn't do that. I guess I was so excited that I have like, what did you get? What did you get? Or what kind of ring?
怎么回事？你本该做的是写上类似于“高尔夫课”之类的内容。对，或者诸如此类愚蠢的屁事。但你没有这么做。我猜我太兴奋了，以至于我心里想——你买了什么？你买了什么？或者是什么样的戒指？
Nothing yet. But I'm gonna go pick it up. Oh, you're gonna go pick it up. Yeah, it's someone of these vintage goddamn things that you can't do. I know the lady. How many years, Jay? Yeah. 20 plus. Wow. So I better get the, Goddamn things that I know the lady. How many years Jay? Yeah
什么都还没买。但我待会儿去拿。哦，你要去拿啊。对，就是那种你没法儿弄的复古该死玩意儿。我认识那家店的老板。多少年了，杰伊？对。20多年。哇。那我最好把……该死的那种玩意儿，我认识那家店的老板。多少年了，杰伊？对
20 plus wow But I better get the better five find out before we hit 25 because 25 is silver Get like the real rank I nailed down the day the number of the actual years Yeah, I'm sorry. Do you know the case that comes up? I think I heard I think I heard our guest is best lap Okay, he has been laughing. Okay, this has been laughing. And how foolish we are. I know, we're wasting his time. I know, we really are.
20多年。哇。但我最好在25周年到来之前把这件事弄好，因为25周年是银婚。得买个真正的戒指。我记下了实际的年数。对，抱歉。你知道接下来发生什么吗？我想我听到……我想我听到我们的嘉宾在大笑了。好吧，他一直在笑。好吧，这说明他一直在笑。而我们是多么愚蠢。我知道，我们在浪费他的时间。我知道，我们真的是。
You know what, I'm stalling because I'm really nervous, actually. I think that's why I'm doing today. Yeah. Yeah, it's so much better when it's not my guest because then I can just hit fucking. You should be back. And I just roll in completely unprepared and I just get to respond like the thing bad I am just hit fucking, and I just roll in completely unprepared,
你知道吗，我在拖延时间，因为我其实真的很紧张。我想这就是我今天在做的事。对。是的，当嘉宾不是我的人时感觉好多了，因为那样我就可以直接操。你本来就该这样。而我就这样完全没有准备地入场，然后只能像个笨蛋一样做出反应。只能操。而我就这样完全没有准备地入场，
and I just get to respond like the thing bad I am. But today, I got, there's a hero here today. Can we have, I can't wait to hear the, I'm so excited for your intro that you've written because these are my least, sorry, favorite parts about, go ahead. I can't sound like you almost said least, Sean. Hey, did, did, did, but I actually really like him, Jay.
然后只能像个笨蛋一样做出反应。但今天，我这里有一位英雄。我们能，我等不及要听，我太期待你写的那段开场白了，因为这些是我最，抱歉，最喜欢的环节，来吧。听起来你刚才差点说成“最不喜欢的”，肖恩。嘿，其实我真的挺喜欢他，杰伊。
There's thought behind them and they're all with you. Thank you. Thank you, Sean. You mean, I don't wing it like lazy boy over there or me. Yeah, or you. All right. Here he comes. Today our guest might be the person I've most wanted to meet in this nutty biz.
里面是有心思的，而且都和你有关。谢谢你。谢谢你，肖恩。你的意思是，我不像那边那个懒骨头一样即兴发挥，或者说我？对，或者你。好啦。他来了。今天我们的嘉宾可能是这个疯狂行业里我最想见的人。
He's a man. You never met him. You never met him. I don't, if I have, I'm going in this nutty biz. He's a master film. You never met him? I don't, if I have, I'm going to be really embarrassed. I don't think I have. I would have remembered. But he's going to tell me maybe if he remembers and we didn't. Sorry.
他是一个男人。你从来没见过他。你从来没见过他。我不知道，如果见过，我在这行里可就太尴尬了。我并不觉得我见过。我肯定会记得的。但他可能会告诉我，如果他记得的话，而我们其实没见过。抱歉。
I don't think we have. He's a master filmmaker and incredibly prolific. He's made his first movie 35 years ago and has made 35 films since. Oh my God. I'm not to mention as many, many projects for the small screen. His films have made over $2 billion and we see 14 Academy Award nominations in 2000.
我觉得我们没见过。他是电影界的大师，而且极其高产。他35年前拍了第一部电影，此后又拍了35部。天哪。更不用说为小银幕制作的许许多多项目了。他的电影票房超过了20亿美元，并在2000年获得了14项奥斯卡提名。
He won the Oscar for Best Director and his odds were good because that year he was nominated for two films. He's come a long way from writing music for game shows and holding cue cards. He's got a couple of kids, a wife named Jules and we're born on the same day, January 14th. Please welcome the one and only Steven Soderbergh. Oh my God. So we're born on the same day. Yeah. Now see, I track you, you don't track me. It's all right. A minute. Yeah. January 14th. it's I shared a birthday with you, LL Cool J and Dave girl.
他赢得了奥斯卡最佳导演奖，而且他当时的胜算很大，因为那一年他有两部电影获得提名。从为游戏节目写音乐和举提示卡开始，他已经走过了漫长的道路。他有一双儿女，一个叫朱尔斯的妻子，而且我们是在同一天出生的——1月14日。请欢迎独一无二的史蒂芬·索德伯格。天哪。所以我们是同一天生日。对。你看，我关注你，你却不关注我。没关系。等等。对。1月14日。我和你、LL Cool J以及戴夫·格罗尔同一天生日。
Well, okay, that's great. Come together again. It is. I would like to see I would like to see that grouping together. Steven Soderberg, welcome to Smarlas. What a cool. It's so nice to meet you. I'm going to be the most boring person here.
好吧，那太棒了。再次聚到一起。确实如此。我很想看到，我很想看到那个组合聚在一起。史蒂芬·索德伯格，欢迎来到“聪明笨蛋”。太酷了。很高兴见到你。我会成为这里最无聊的人。
How does this work? How do what do I do? We're just going to bullshit. No, listen, are you sure? When we're starting with you? How does this work? What do I do? We're just going to bullshit. Listen, are you sure? When we're starting recording, we will tell you who the most boring people. Yeah, I can't. Listen, we're starting with a great Soderbergh piece of composition here.
这怎么运作？怎么，我该做点什么？我们就是随便瞎扯。不，听着，你确定吗？我们要从你开始吗？这怎么运作？我该做点什么？我们就是随便瞎扯。听着，你确定吗？当我们开始录音时，我们会告诉你谁是最无聊的人。对，我不行。听着，我们以索德伯格的一段精彩构图开场。
He's got a frame left or frame right. He's got a spiral staircase cutting through the ceiling. It's like a cool shot. And it's a low angle. We've got a nice palette going. Steven, it's just, you never stop being great, right? This is the bunker. This is the bunker.
他的构图里左边有画面边框，右边有画面边框。有一座螺旋楼梯穿过天花板。这就像是一个很酷的镜头。而且是个低角度。我们有一个很棒的色调。史蒂芬，这简直是……你永远都不会停止伟大，对吧？这里是掩体。这里是掩体。
This is the bunker. This is the bunker. All right, now, Steven. Where do we start with? I know because I could, there's a lot. Sean's got, as he would say, 9,000 questions for you or 17,000 questions. For all the listeners I see people always go, Sean always says I've got 9,000 questions or 17,000.
这里是掩体。这里是掩体。好了，史蒂芬。我们从哪里开始？我知道，因为我可以，有太多话题了。正如肖恩自己会说的，他为你准备了9000个问题，或者说17000个问题。对于所有的听众，我看到人们总是说，肖恩总是说我有9000个问题或者17000个问题。
You know what? He does. So F off. So steven. I, I've often felt like and I, and I feel like I've seen this out there before. So maybe it was informed by that and maybe it wasn't my original idea. But I've often felt like when people talk about independent film,
你知道吗？他确实有。所以滚蛋吧。所以，史蒂芬。我，我经常觉得，而且我觉得我在别的地方也看到过这种说法；所以也许我是受此启发，也许这不是我原创的想法。但我经常觉得，当人们谈论独立电影时，
an independent film, the 90s where it's real heyday, that was sort of the genesis of the, you know, we had the oterus from the 70s, but then the 90s were like, it was like a whole new movement. And I feel like you were sort of on the cutting edge of that.
独立电影在90年代迎来了真正的全盛时期，那可以说是……你知道，我们有70年代的作者电影，但90年代则像是一场全新运动的起源。我觉得你当时可以说是走在那场运动的前沿。
It's sex lies in videotape was late 80s, I'm gonna say like 80, 89, 89, 89. Sex lies in videotape really was the kicking off point for, and was the beginning of this sort of golden age of independent film. And you are really, really in a lot of ways the Godfather of that. And then you went on to make so many unbelievably incredible
《性、谎言和录像带》是在80年代末，我想大概是80、89年吧，89年，89年。《性、谎言和录像带》确实是……的起点，也是独立电影这个黄金时代开端。在很多方面，你真的可以说是它的教父。然后你又去拍摄了如此之多难以置信的、不可思议的
films, some with bigger budgets, some not, but you've always maintained, there's something about the way that you've kind of kept that sort of independent spirit within the framework of the studio system. And I don't know if you agree with me or disagree with me, but is that something that was always,
电影，有些预算较大，有些则不然，但你始终保持着一种风格——你以某种方式将那种独立精神保持在了制片厂体制的框架之内。我不知道你是否同意我的看法，但这是否一直是……
I don't know, is that something that's part of you the way that you approach making films? I just a terrible question, but I think you know what I'm getting at. Yeah, I think I do. I think it comes down to all of the films that I saw that influenced me that I felt were great, had a signature.
我不知道，这是否是你拍电影方式的一部分？我这个问题提得真烂，但我猜你知道我想表达什么。对，我想我懂。我觉得这归根结底在于，所有对我有影响的、我觉得很伟大的电影，都有鲜明的个人签名。
They were made by, they felt as though they were made by an individual. And so, my goal coming up on the heels of what's often called the American New Wave that followed the new wave that came from Europe and other parts of the world. That was what made this feel new. We knew that there were studio films made by certain directors that had a certain signature. But the idea that that that that tradition over time on a percentage basis yielded better movies was not an idea that emerged until this new wave showed up and people like me who wanted to make movies were watching these movies and feeling like there was a difference between something that felt made by a person and something that felt made by a company.
它们是由……感觉就像是由某一个独立个人制作的。所以，紧随通常被称为“美国新浪潮”（它继承自欧洲和世界其他地区的浪潮）之后，我的目标就是让这种感觉焕然一新。我们知道，某些导演在制片厂拍的电影带有某种个人风格。但是，“这种传统随着时间的推移，按比例能产出更好的电影”这个概念，直到这场新浪潮出现、像我这样想拍电影的人看着这些电影并感觉到由个人制作的作品与由公司制作的产品之间存在区别时，才真正诞生。
Right. And that, I just felt, well, I want to do that. That's what I want to be a part of. And I've tried to maintain that and also sort of brainwash, you know, other people around me and behind me to sign on to that idea.
没错。当时我就觉得，嗯，我想那样做。那是我想要参与其中的领域。我也一直在努力保持这一点，并且还试图给身边的、后辈的其他所有人“洗脑”，让他们也认同这个理念。
Well, not a... But you also did this thing where you, you, sorry Jason, but I just wanted to sort of still on this, where you made all these films and a lot of them very, all of them, very different from, from the next. And a lot of, I find that a lot of filmmakers have a signature style or a thing that they do that makes, you know, but that you have been able to sort of constantly change not necessarily the way you make films, but certainly, totally the way that you really lean into whatever it is that film that you're doing and you make it to that.
好吧，不仅如此……但你也做过这样一件事——抱歉，杰森，但我只是想在这个话题上再深入一点——你拍了所有这些电影，其中很多，或者说全部，部部风格迥异。我发现很多电影导演都有标志性的风格或惯用伎俩，这使得……你知道的。但你却能够不断地改变——不一定是改变你拍电影的方式，但绝对是彻底改变你倾注到手头那部电影中的心力，并让电影去适应那种风格。
They're all very, very different. And I think it's such a testament to, I don't know. Like a lack of originality. No, no, no, no, you can't pigeonhole you. You can't pigeonhole you. Yeah, no, but that's, I'm a synthesis. I mean, I can tell you that right now, I'm a synthesis. I know the difference between somebody who's a true original
它们全都不尽相同。我觉得这真是对……我不知道。就像缺乏原创性一样。不，不，不，不，你不能把你自己归入某种刻板印象。你不能把你框定。对，不，但那是……我是一个合成体。我的意思是，我现在就可以告诉你，我是一个合成体。我知道真正的原创者和……之间的区别
and somebody who's a synthesis original and somebody who's a synthesis. I've seen it, I've met them, I'm a synthesis. I don't look at anything I've done and gone, well I did that first, like that's not true. What I do and what I like to do is see as much as I can see and attach to as much as I can attach to that I think is really compelling and then put it in a bucket and you know stew it around as I'm envisioning whatever the next thing is and go okay I can use that I can use that I can use that I'm going to save those other things. They don't work for this.
合成原创者和……的区别人。我见过，我也遇到过，我是一个合成体。我不会看着自己做过的任何事情然后说，“哦，那是我首创的”——因为那不是真的。我所做的事、我喜欢做的事，是尽可能多地去看，尽可能多地去吸收那些我认为真正引人入胜的东西，然后把它们放进一个大熔炉里，（在构思下一部作品时）把它们搅拌在一起，然后心想：好吧，这个我能用，那个我能用，这个我也能用，剩下的那些先留着。那些不适用于这部作品。
I'll kick those down the road. But I'm just taking in anything I think is good. A shot, a line, a transition, an idea, a font, anything. Yeah. I'm looking for anything. So you don't, you kind of already just answer this, but I was gonna say, so you don't consciously seek out, like I wanna do a big gigantic franchise for a studio, because I have dollar signs in my eyes or whatever.
我以后再慢慢琢磨。但我会吸收任何我认为好的东西。一个镜头、一句台词、一次转场、一个点子、一种字体，什么都行。是的。我什么都在找。所以你其实……你刚才已经回答了这个问题，但我本来想说的是，你并不是那种会有意识地去寻找的人——比如“我想为制片厂拍一部宏大的特许经营大片”，因为我眼里闪烁着金钱的符号或者别的什么。
You'd rather go for idea, for whatever speaks to you personally, right? I mean, it's a dumb question, but you kind of just said it, correct? Well, I'm looking potentially through two different lenses. If there's nothing immediately in front of me, I'm just watching things to pick up new ideas and new information. Yeah. If there's something then that I focus on, oh, I'm going to do this next, then I start to telescope that toward things that I think have been really good in that space.
你宁愿去追求创意，追求那些能触动你个人内心的东西，对吧？我的意思是，这是一个愚蠢的问题，但你刚才其实已经说过了，对吧？嗯，我可能是在通过两个不同的视角来看待这个问题。如果眼前没有什么迫在眉睫的事情，我只是在看各种东西来汲取新的创意和新的信息。是的。如果随后有什么东西让我聚焦，比如“我接下来要做这个”，那么我就会开始把视野收窄到那些我认为在这个领域里真正优秀的东西上。
Yeah, because I think what's fascinating is with somebody like you and your brain, I'm sure lots of people want, we always ask this of people that are as successful as you as like, we try to get inside in the head and be like, what informs your decisions because they seem to be always correct? That's what's fascinating to me is like finding out what, where that comes from inside of you,
对，因为我觉得最 fascinating（迷人）的是，像你这样的人和你的大脑，我确信有很多人都想……我们总是向像你这么成功的人打听这种事，我们试图走进你的脑海，想知道是什么在指引你的决策，因为你的决定似乎总是正确的？最让我着迷的是去弄清楚，那种……那种能力源自你内心的什么地方，
rather than this is a great story I've never seen it. It's kind of speak to something even deeper than that. And I'm always fascinated with people with your track record. It's like, God, you get it right time after time after time after time. What is that secret sauce? I look, if I knew what it was, I would tell you. But I would keep it from me. No, because I'm honestly, I'm the son of a teacher.
而不是仅仅因为这是一个我没见过的伟大故事。它往往触及比这更深层次的东西。我总是对有着你这样履历的人充满着迷。简直是，天哪，你一次又一次、一次又一次地做对了。那秘诀到底是什么？听着，如果我知道那是什么，我一定会告诉你。但我会对自己保密。不，因为说实话，我是个教师的儿子。
I'm an open source person. I don't keep anything that I've learned, private, even when people wish that I would. So, you know, it's purely a question of taste, which to get to the good version of something. And while doing that, in my view, and this is really important, creating an atmosphere of creativity, you don't do the shit by yourself. Creating an environment in which people are thinking about the thing. They're not thinking about you and how you're behaving.
我是个开源的人。我不会把任何我学到的东西私藏起来，哪怕有时候别人希望我这么做。所以，你知道，这纯粹是一个品味问题，也就是如何达到某种事物的最佳版本。而在做这件事的过程中，依我之见——这一点非常重要——那就是营造一种富有创造力的氛围。你不可能一个人搞定这种屁事。要创造一个让大家都在思考作品本身的环境。他们不是在想你、也不是在想你的行为举止。
They're thinking about the thing. And so you're in this continual conversation about what is the thing, what is the best version of this thing? If it's going good, you go with that and it's flowing. When it pushes back at you, what's your sort of checklist for why, you know, it's pushing back why. It was going fine. Now we've hit a bump. What's the, what are the questions I need to ask
他们满脑子想的都是作品本身。所以你会处于一种持续的对话中：这东西到底是什么？这个东西的最佳版本是什么？如果一切顺利，你就顺其自然，进展就会非常流畅。当遇到阻力时，你用来排查原因的清单是什么？比如：事情原本进展顺利，现在碰壁了。问题出在哪里？我需要问自己什么问题
to get to the solve? Yeah. There's no shortcut to that other than being on the floor. Right. So you very humbly say that you're a more of a synthesizer than something else. But what would you say to anybody out there listening that might be thinking about becoming a director and weighing the effort of education in that space and taking directing classes
才能找到解决办法？是的。除了身临现场之外，没有别的捷径可走。好吧。所以你非常谦虚地称自己更多是一个合成体，而不是别的什么。但对于任何正在听节目的、可能考虑成为导演、并在“该领域接受教育的付出”与“上导演课（或同等性质的学习，无论那是什么）”之间权衡的人，你会说些什么？你所做的事情中，有多少是你学来的技术，又有多少正如你所说，只是在综合你所观察到、喜爱的各种元素，然后运用你的品味将它们组合在一起，并在现场随机应变？嗯，每当有人问我“我应该去电影学校吗”
or the equal of that, whatever that is. Like how much of what you do is technique that you've learned and how much of it is, as you say, just synthesizing different elements that you've observed, liked and then now you're just executing taste and putting together a combination of all those things and reacting on the fly. Well, whenever I'm asked, should I get a film school,
或者有家长问“我的孩子应该去电影学校吗”，我的回答总是：听着，哪怕只是为了加入一个帮派，这也值了。我不认为任何人能教出什么……如果一个人有天赋，他就是有天赋，他自然会好起来的。但你需要一个帮派，就像你需要一个群体一样，你需要……我当年就有，我很幸运，我在高中而不是在大学里就有了这个。所以我很幸运。但我们是一个帮派。我们是一群想要拍电影、一直在拍短片、并且在彼此的项目里包办一切的人。所以，如果这是你从电影学校得到的唯一收获，那其实也是巨大的收获。是的，我对大学的看法也是如此，
or if some parent asks, should my child get a film school? My response is that, look, if only to be part of a gang, it's worth it. I don't think anybody is going to teach, if they're good, they're good, and they will, they'll be fine. But you need a gang, like you need a group, you need, I had it, I just was lucky, I had it in high school instead of in college. So I just got lucky. But we were a gang. We were a gang of people that wanted to make movies and we're making short films, doing everything on everybody's projects. And so if that's the only thing you got out of going to film school, that's huge actually. Yeah, I would say that about college,
那就是大学更多地教会了我……关于社交。是的，完全正确，完全正确。我们马上回来。“聪明笨蛋”由BetterHelp赞助。你知道的，我记得我年轻时，作为演员去为工作试镜却没被选上，那时你开始怀疑自我，
is like college was more, taught me more about. It's about socializing. Yes, exactly, exactly. And we will be right back. Smartless is sponsored by better help. You know, I remember when I was younger, auditioning for jobs as an actor and not getting them and you kind of start to doubt yourself
思考自己选择的道路是否正确。我到底该不该做这个？支撑我度过难关的是对自己的信念和自信，而我获得自信的方式其实是把内心的想法说出来，勇敢地表达、展现脆弱、坦诚相待并积极沟通。所以，有时在生活中，当我们面临艰难的选择、前方的道路并非总是清晰可见时——
and think about your path that you choose the right one. Am I supposed to be doing this at all? And what got me through it is the belief in myself and the confidence and how I got that was actually talking about it and being vocal and vulnerable and honest and communicative. So sometimes in life where faced with tough choices and the path forward isn't always clear.
无论你是在处理关于职业、人际关系还是其他任何事情的决定，心理疗法都能帮助你在人海航行中与自己真正想要的东西保持联系，从而满怀自信与兴奋地向前迈进。相信自己能做出符合价值观的决定，这与其他事情一样。你练习得越多，事情就变得越容易。我从心理治疗中受益匪浅。
Whether you're dealing with decisions around career, relationships or anything else, therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life so you can move forward with confidence and excitement. Trusting yourself to make decisions that align with your values is like anything. The more you practice it, the easier it gets. I've benefited from therapy.
我经常谈论它。它总能帮我度过坎坷的境地。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的心理治疗师进行匹配，
I talk about it all the time. It always gets me through bumpy situations. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist
并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。让心理疗法成为你的人生指南，BetterHelp为你护航。今天就访问betterhelp.com斜线smartlist，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是betterhelp.h-l-p.com斜线smartless。“聪明笨蛋”获得了服装品牌Vuori的支持。厌倦了为了舒适而牺牲时尚，反之亦然吗？伙们，不用再找了，Vuori就是那个将两者完美结合的高性能服装品牌。
and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smart list today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp.hlp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from Viori clothing. Tired of sacrificing style for comfort or vice versa, guys look no further than Viori, the performance clothing brand that combines both.
Vuori提供地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装，是对你快乐生活的完美投资。从慢跑裤到打底裤再到圆领衫，无论你在做什么，Vuori都能满足你保持舒适和时尚的一切需求。我有一条防撕裂长裤，非常棒，因为它的侧面有一个小口袋，我可以把钥匙随手扔进去。所以当我出门跑步时，轰的一下，钥匙装好。
Viori offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet, making it the perfect investment in your happiness. From joggers to leggings to crewnecks, Viori has everything you need to stay comfy and stylish no matter what you're doing. So I have the RIP stop pant, which is great because it has a little pocket on the side and you just throw my keys in there. So when I'm running outside, boom, go my keys.
我准备出发了。我买了一条新裤子，是芝麻色的。这就是那个颜色，你们听清了。为了回馈听众，他们提供首次购买八折优惠。快去Vuori.com斜线smartless，为自己添置一些地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装吧。网址是V-U-O-R-I点com斜线SmartLess。
I'm set to go. I got a new pair, in Sesame. That's the color, you heard me. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartless. That's a V-U-O-R-I dot com slash SmartLess.
你不仅能享受首次购买八折优惠，凡是在美国境内订单满75美元的，还可以享受免运费和免费退货服务。快去Vuori.com斜线SmartLess，探索Vuori服装的多功能性吧。“聪明笨蛋”由State Farm（州立农业保险）支持。有时候保险可能会让人感到困惑，对吧？由State Farm支持。有时候保险可能会让人感到困惑，对吧？
Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash SmartLess and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. SmartLess is supported by State Farm. Insurance can be confusing sometimes, right? That supported by State Farm. Insurance can be confusing sometimes, right?
这就是为什么State Farm会为你的各种“万一”保驾护航。因为他们知道你生活中的其他时间，已经塞满了对各种事情的思考，比如：如果你的生活是一份播放列表会怎么样？想象一下那会有多疯狂。你的第一首歌曲可能是一首吵闹的轨道，名字叫……我不知道，叫“孩子”。第二首，是一首毛骨悚然的轨道，叫“拥有房产”。然后还有大约一百首叫作“工作、健康、宠物、汽车、庭院劳作”的歌。
That's why State Farm is there for your what ifs. Because they know the rest of your life is already full of thinking about other things, like what if your life was a playlist? Imagine how crazy it would be. Your first song might be a noisy track called, I don't know, Kids. The second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership. Then like a hundred more songs called Work, Health, Pets, Cars, Yardwork.
我不知道，播放列表就这样一直放下去。一旦你把它设置为单曲循环再开启随机播放模式，事情听起来可就不那么美妙了。这就是为什么你最不想加进人生播放列表的最后一首歌，叫做“保险不确定性”，里面夹杂着这样的歌词：“万一我想在保单里增加理赔范围呢？”“万一我在凌晨3点遇到问题怎么办？”
I don't know, the playlist goes on. And once you put it on repeat and add shuffle mode, things might not sound all that jazzy. That's why the last track you'd wanna add to your life's playlist is called Insurance Uncertainties with lyrics like, what if I'd like to add coverage to my policy? What if I have a question at 3 a.m.?
好吧，这里有一些积极的音符，可以帮助你的生活保持和谐。你可以在State Farm移动应用程序上提交理赔申请，与真人沟通（包括你的专属保险经纪人），而且你可以不分昼夜地就保险范围和保单问题打电话咨询，因为这正是他们所做的。所以，无论你的生活变得多么喧嚣，保险依然可以化作你耳畔的美妙音乐。
Well, there are some positive notes that can help keep your life in harmony. You can file a claim on the State Farm Mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions, because that's just what they do. So, no matter how noisy your life may get, insurance can still be music to your ears.
犹如好邻居，State Farm就在你身边。今天就打电话或访问StateFarm.com获取报价吧。现在回到节目中。说到帮派，你经常和同一拨人合作，或者你和同一拨人合作过……你经常和同一拨人合作，或者你和同一拨人合作过很多次，其中有两个人是我们这个小小聊天节目的老嘉宾：乔治·克鲁尼和马特·达蒙。考虑到他们有限的才华水平，你觉得为什么这俩人还能接这么多活儿？
Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. Call or go to StateFarm.com for a quote today. And now back to the show. Speaking of a gang, you often work with the same people or you've worked with the same people a gang, you often work with the same people or you've worked with the same people a lot, two of which are our past guests on this little chat show, George Clooney and Matt Damon. Why do you think those two have managed to work so much given their limited level of talent?
马特他妈的到底凭什么？对。居然混了过来。马特真的是，真的是，真的是混过来了。对，所以你要为此承担部分责任。但为什么你对他们说了那么多次“好”呢？他们抓了你的什么把柄吗？还是说原因是什么？
Why the fuck is Matt? Yeah. Wiggled through. Matt is really, really, really through. Yeah, and so you're partly to blame for this. But why was it that you said yes to them so many times? Did they have stuff on you? Or what is that?
这，这，这，这简直是卑鄙。对。这很有意思，因为就乔治而言，你知道，我们相遇的时候，我们俩都被视为某种“问号”人物。那甚至还没……那是《战略高手》时期吗？那是你们……《战略高手》之前。这是《战略高手》之前。所以在《性、谎言》之后，我拍了五部没人看、而且也没多少人喜欢的作品。
It's, it's, it's, it's craven. Yeah. It's, it was funny because in the case of George, you know, we met at a time where both of us were viewed as kind of question marks. It was we hadn't was that was that out of sight? Was that when you guys were... Pre-out of sight. This is pre-out of sight. So after sex lies, I've made five things that nobody saw, and not a lot of people liked.
而乔治当时正成为一颗巨大的电视明星，拍的电影票房还算过得去，但无论出于什么原因，似乎都没能捕捉到构成乔治本色的精髓。所以我们俩都处在一个有点诡异的过渡期。当时我并不是首选。我得等别人挑剩了才轮到我。
And George was becoming a giant TV star and making movies that were doing okay, but for whatever reason, didn't seem to be capturing the essence of what makes George. And so we were both in this kind of weird, transitional space. It was a thing that I was not front of line. I had to wait for people to pass.
我觉得我知道那是什么。我当时就觉得我知道那是什么。我说，乔治已经确定参演了，我说这就是我认为的感觉，他们也赞同这一点。正是杰西电影公司（Jersey Films）和乔治的支持，才让我得到了那份工作。当时我的事业可以说是跌入冰点。而那种合作，对我们俩来说，都把故事导向了不同的方向。对，插个话。当你看到……我们还是直说吧。
And I felt like I knew what it was. I just felt like I knew what it was. And I went, George was already attached. And I said, here's what I think it is, and they agreed with that. And it was a Jersey films and George's support that got me that job. I could not have been colder at that point. And that kind of for both of us just took the narrative in a different direction. Yeah, sidebar. When you look, let's be a go ahead and say.
我刚才本来想说，在镜头背后，我们是允许插话的。对，顺便说一句，这绝对是个好主意，是我们节目的特色。对，当你在真正……这真是一个他妈的突发情况。不过请继续，插话。不，我本来想说马特·达蒙，
I was just to say, behind the candle, we're allowing sidebars. Yeah, I didn't, by the way, big go ahead, part of our show. Yeah, when you're really, it's a fucking new incident. But go ahead, sidebar. No, I was gonna say Matt Damon,
我们在他开始拍摄《烛台背后》之前一起吃晚饭，他对我说——我可能会记错，他要是知道了肯定会杀了我的——但大概意思是：肖恩，我不知道该怎么做。
and I were having dinner right before he started showing behind the candle, LaBra, and he said to me, I'm gonna get this wrong and he's gonna kill me, but it was something like Sean, I don't know what to do.
你觉得我在电影里和迈克尔·道格拉斯亲热这事儿怎么样？就像这样。他说，观众会沉浸在我的角色中吗？我说，当然。他们说观众会写关于……那部分的内容吗？诸如此类的话。我说，当然啦，你们
What do you think about me making out with Michael Douglas in this movie, like so? He goes, are people gonna be able to lose themselves in my role? I was like, well of course, they said are people gonna write about like that part? Something like that. And I said, well of course you guys
俩都是才华横溢的演员，但不行，媒体绝对会拍照片的。你知道的，剧照，我会说：当然啦，你们俩都是才华横溢的演员，但不行，媒体绝对会拍照片的。你知道的，剧照，我会说：马特·达蒙和迈克尔·道格拉斯在这部电影里亲热。所以这是没办法的，你避不开这个。太搞笑了。我说我为什么要问这个？我本来想问你，我到底该怎么……我该怎么去亲吻一个男人？
are both brilliant actors, but no, the press is definitely gonna take photos. And you know, the stills, I'm gonna say, of course you guys are both brilliant actors, but no, the press is definitely going to take photos. And you know, the stills, I'm going to say, Matt Damon and Michael Douglas are making out in this movie. Like, there's no, you can't avoid that. It was so funny. And I'm like, why am I asking? I was going to ask you, how do I really, how do I kiss a man?
对，然后我说，你想对对台词吗？就像我临时要求来个工作坊排练一样。你……那是在拍戏结束的时候吗？这可不只是我的小故事。他当时说：不，不。怎么才能避开……不。关于这事的媒体报道。我在开拍前一天见到了他，他说：
Yeah, and I was like, I said, do you want to run lines? Like I asked for a workshop that real quick. Do you, that was at the end of the season? That's not just my little story. He was like, no, no. How do I avoid, no. Press of that. I saw in the day before we started shooting, and he said,
他说，我和这个演员吃了一顿糟糕透顶的晚餐。肖恩。他的首字母缩写是肖恩·海斯（Sean Hayes）？他的首字母缩写是肖恩·海斯？他的首字母缩写是肖恩·海斯。对。他的首字母缩写是shh。这也是我从杰森那里经常听到的。对。
He said, I had this terrible dinner with this actor. Sean. Who's initials are Sean Hayes? Who's initials are Sean Hayes? Who's initials are Sean Hayes. Yeah. Who's initials are shh. And that's all I hear from Jason as well. Yeah.
然后他说，我想弄清楚我应该把表演的基调定在哪里。我说，我想明天当你把整套造型穿上身的时候，你就会确切地知道那是什么感觉了。如果你是个演员，这就是为什么我拼命试图避免和演员就我们要尝试的一个场景进行那种高谈阔论的知识分子式对话。这是身体层面的。如果身体上的感觉对了，那一切就都对了。所以这要从服装开始，字面意义上就是如此。
And he goes, I want to be clear about where I should be pitching this. And I said, I think tomorrow when you put the whole thing on, you'll know exactly what it is. If you're an actor, this is why I tried desperately to not engage in sort of intellectual conversations with an actor about a scene that we're trying. It's physical. If the physical stuff's right, it's gonna be right. And so that starts with the wardrobe, literally it does.
比如：我穿什么鞋，我看起来像什么，什么？对，因为这很有帮助。这太有帮助了。你对你身上穿的衣服满意吗？你不满意吗？这绝对是其中的一部分，我想让它变得身体力行。我当时就说，当你把那个发型和那些东西戴上之后，
Like, what am I shoes, what am I like, what? Yeah, because it helps. It helps so much. Are you happy in what you're wearing? Are you not happy in what you're wearing? Like, it's a part of the fact, I wanna make it physical. And I just said, when you put that hair and the stuff on,
你就会变成那个家伙。没错。对，杰森，如果你和史蒂芬合作的话，你觉得自己会在片场和他争论吗？因为他不会把事情知识分子化。我知道你喜欢用你那些愚蠢的问题把人折磨得精疲力竭。你觉得作为……抱歉，让我重新开始。作为艺术家，或者作为真正的大师。
you're gonna be that guy. That's right. Yeah, Jason, do you see yourself arguing with Stephen on set if you're working together? Because he won't intellectualize. And I know that you like to grind people to a fine nub with your stupid questions. Do you find, as, sorry, let me just start that again. As artists, or as they're from the true Nazter.
我知道，我知道，我知道，我是在跟你逗着玩呢。好吧，不过让我问问杰森，让我问你几个问题。所以乔治，乔治在我们合作之后成为了一名导演。《危险思想的自白》。很棒的导演。对，马特以后也会成为一个好导演的。成为了一名导演。《危险思想的自白》。很棒的导演。对，马特以后也会成为一个好导演的。
I know, I know, I know, I'm fucking with you. Okay, but let me ask Jason, let me ask you a few questions. So George, George subsequent to us working together then became a director. Confessions of a dangerous man. Great director. Yeah, and Matt would be a great director too. became a director. Confessions of a dangerous money. Great director. Yeah. And Matt would be a great director too.
我也这么认为。对，肯定的。他已经等了很久了，不是吗？时候快到了。但我不会重复乔治在执导完他的第一部电影后对我说过的话，关于演员的评价。对，拜托，你得说出来。
I think so too. Yeah for sure. He's waited a long time, isn't he? It's coming. But I will not repeat what George said to me after having directed his first film about actors. Yeah. Oh, come on, you gotta say it.
你必须说出来。我才不……我刚才已经说了。我无法想象。对，我能想象。你知道我的意思吗？他当时有一种非常……他说，听起来很显眼，像个陈词滥调，但我现在对“当别人向我走来时会发生什么”有了非常、非常不同的看法。对，但是，但是，杰森，杰森，你以前也对我说过类似的话，无论是在这里还是在别的地方，你当时就
You gotta say it. I don't, I just said it. I can't imagine. Yeah, I can imagine. You know what I mean? He just had a very, he's like, wow, I, he goes, sounds obvious and like a cliche, but I have a very, very different view now of what happens when somebody comes at me, isn't it? Yeah, but, but Jay, Jay, you said that similarly to me here and outside of here, where you just
像……我只想搞懂你。对，就好像……我只想搞懂你。你根本不会意识到，一个有帮助的演员能起到多大的作用。噢，老兄，真的能救你的命。除非你当了导演，因为在“开拍”到“停机”之间，导演是完全无助的。你完全要依赖摄影师、大抓片（推轨助理）、演员、收音师、以及所有其他人——别把事情搞砸，试着让所有部门融为一体，并且意识到你是在与其他各个部门共舞。
like, I want to get you. Yeah, it's just like, I want to get you. You don't appreciate how, how helpful a helpful actor can be. Oh, dude, can save your ass. Until you direct, because it's between action and cut, the director is completely helpless. You are fully reliant on the operator, the dollar grip, the actor, the boom operator, everybody to not fuck it up and just try to make everything coalesce and be aware that you're dancing with other departments.
可能有些工作不在镜头前，但这一切都必须协同运作。如果你能对整个制作流程以及所有这些细节保持一半的关注，那么像乔治或马特这样拥有极高片场智商的人，就能在拍摄进行的同时提供帮助。而乔治，一旦他开始导演生涯，肯定对这一点有了更深的体会。但杰森，你刚才说了一句非常聪明的话。
It might not be on camera, but but it's all got to work. And if you can kind of keep half an eye on the process and all that, so if somebody like George or Matt who both have the huge set IQs, they can help while things are rolling. And George certainly, once he started directing, probably realize that even more. But Jay, you said something really smart.
他们就像是……我不，我觉得那好像是在这儿说的。你当时说了一些类似于……越是……而且我正看着我的日历。对，希望这段录下来了。你说过，共用日历——和杰森的妻子共用日历。我刚才说什么了？我很开心。不，我本来想说的是，你当时说了一些关于……
They're like, I don't, I think it was on here. You've seen something like the more, and I'm looking at my calendar. Yeah, hopefully it's recorded. You said, share calendar, a share calendar with Jason's wife. What did I say? I was happy. No, what I was going to say, you said something about like,
与演员合作是怎么样的，比如，你……你提到过一个界限，就是你和他们进行这些精彩的讨论，但你知道在什么时候该结束，因为如果你纠缠太久，就会达到这样一个地步：聊到最后大家只是在原地绕圈子，或者诸如此类的话。对，归根结底，这不由你导演说了算。演员最终会尽其所能、发挥出他们所能达到的最高水平。
what was like working with the actors about like, you, there's a you said something about like, double-sided work. Working with actors about like, there's a line where you have these great discussions with them, but you know where to end them, because if you engage too long, you reach a point where you're just talking in circles after a while or something like that. Yeah, and ultimately like, it's not up to you, director. Like the actor's gonna do what what that actor can do the best they
史蒂芬，我读到过你说过的话——我这里显然是在意译——但它的核心精神大体是：你保持着一种很轻描淡写的导演风格，因为你意识到最好的结果来自于由舒适、自信和安全感所构成的氛围，你会不断鼓励他们。我想你当时大概说过：我想确保每个人都好好的。然后你会让他们所有人都保持在正轨上。相比之下，那种更具指令性的导演风格则是：
possibly can do it. And I've read Stephen that you've said that, I'm paraphrasing here obviously, but basically the spirit of it was you have a very light touch because you realize that the best results will come from the atmosphere, up comfort and confidence and safety and you will encourage them. I think you said something like, I wanna make sure everybody's okay. And then you'll keep them all on the rails. As opposed to a more sort of prescriptive version
“我看到你在读这个词时语调上扬了，也许在台词结尾时要降下来，然后坐在那边……”这种事经常发生。不，但必须有一个结构，必须得有一个拍板决定的人。我的目标是让整个制作过程感觉像是在有机地演变，但这本质上是一个信任问题——如果归根结底，
of directing, which is, you know, I see you going up on this word and maybe come back down at the end of the line and then sit down over here like it happens all the time. No, but there has to be a structure, there has to be a decider. What my goal is to just have the process feel like it's evolving organically, but it's really a trust issue that if it all comes down to,
当我开口说“不，那样不管用”时，你是相信我的。没错。我叫停绝不是出于其他原因，而是因为我已经把带有这个桥段的所有版本都在脑子里推演过了。我告诉你，这就像是一个必须被切除的肿瘤。那根本不合适。我们之间已经建立起足够的信任，因为你过去通常都一针见血。
when I say, no, that doesn't work, you believe me. Right. It's not, I'm not shutting you down for any other reason than I've gained out all the versions of this with that in it. And I'm telling you, it's an org that needs to be extracted. That doesn't fit. That we have enough of a relationship because you've usually been spot on.
当我拒绝说“不，那样行不通”时，你是相信我的。没错。我并不是出于别的理由而否定你，而是我已经把所有包含那个元素的版本都推演过了。我是在告诉你，那是一个需要被剔除的组织部分。那不合适。我们之间有足够的信任基础，因为你过去通常都切中要害。
You know what I mean? When you go like, hey, what if I do, what if the, and I go, yes, that's good, chase that. Right. But when I go, no, that doesn't work because of X that then we move on. And I'm sure you carry a lot more credibility than other directors do with some actors, because you're actually oftentimes holding the camera and you have written it and you're
你知道我的意思吗？当你去说，嘿，如果我这样做，如果那个……然后我说，对，那个好，就顺着这个思路。没错。但当我说，不，那个行不通，因为有X原因，然后我们就会继续。而且我确信，比起其他导演，你和一些演员在一起时更有信服力，因为你实际上经常亲自扛着摄像机，而且剧本是你写的，你还要
going to be editing it. Like you've got your arms around completely around all the projects that you do and the in the best way. And I was so envious that you know how to operate and that you know how to edit and know how to write and all that stuff. It's right. Yeah. I was going to ask a real well I was going to ask if I could Sean because you've had two sidebars and three questions. You derailed the entire thing just to side bar and now we're on to loose quotes that Jason's got of even I think you want said. No, we're actually I mean I'm putting George in his mouth. This is just an absolute affront to the man. I would I would I want him to get back to just just because you touched
亲自剪辑。就像你完全、用最好的方式掌控了你所做的所有项目。我真是嫉妒你会操作机器，会剪辑，会写作，诸如此类。没错。是的。我本来想问个真——嗯，肖恩，我本来想问行不行，因为你已经插话了两次，问了三个问题。你把整场访谈都带偏了，就为了插话，现在我们又扯到了杰森随口说的、甚至可能是你觉得你想说的话上。不，其实我——我是把话塞进乔治嘴里。这对这位先生简直是一种侮辱。我——我——我想让他回到——就因为你之前提到了
on it before you talked about when you were early on, when you and George got together, and you started, and you'd been making some films that nobody knew that nobody had seen, or whatever, you're a very, for, as a director, you're very prolific. Unusually, I'm usually so, I would say, to the extent that not, two of the better directors, American directors,
早期的事，你和乔治刚聚在一起的时候，你们刚开始合作，那时你们拍了一些没人知道、没人看过的电影，诸如此类的。作为一个导演，你非常高产。不同寻常的高产，我通常会说，甚至可以说，在过去的30年里，美国最优秀的两位导演
in the last 30 years are you and Todd Field. And Todd's made five films, I don't, I call him Todd, I don't know him. He's made five films and you've made sort of 30. He's made three. Maybe he's made three. Is it three? Three. Yeah.
就是你和托德·菲尔德。托德拍了五部电影，我不知道——我叫他托德，我又不认识他。他拍了五部电影，而你大概拍了30部。他拍了三部。也许他拍了三部。是三部吗？三部。对。
Wow. In the bedroom, little children and tar, that's it. Is that hit? Yep. Features. I mean, incredible. A thousand commercials. That's really the exact commercial. Yeah, features. I mean, incredible. A thousand commercials. That's really the exact commercial.
哇。《卧室风波》、《身为人母》和《塔尔》，就这样。是这样吗？对。故事片。我的天，难以置信。拍了一千部广告。那确实是——准确地说，广告。对，故事片。我的天，难以置信。拍了一千部广告。那确实是——准确地说，广告。
Yeah, yeah. But, and you've made a lot, and again, maybe 30 or 25 or something like that. And you've both made great movies. Is there something to, for you as an artist, do you enjoy that process of constantly creating concerts? You need to be constantly creating, because you don't have to do it. I guess you just want to. Well, you thought about not doing it anymore for a little while, and then it was just to hiatus, yeah?
对，对。但是，你拍了很多，再说一次，也许是30部或25部左右。而且你们两个都拍出了伟大的电影。对你作为一个艺术家来说，这种不断创作的过程是不是有什么吸引力？你需要不断地创作吗，因为你其实不必这么做？我想你只是想这样做。好吧，你有一小段时间考虑过不再拍了，然后那只是个暂时的停歇，对吧？
Yeah, that was boy. That was embarrassing. Um. We're not going to let that go. Probably this quoted or overly-quoted. No, no, no. That was the problem. I was very accurately quoted.
对，那真是——天哪。那太尴尬了。嗯。我们不会就这么放过这事的。可能被断章取义了，或者被过度解读了。不，不，不。问题就在这。我被非常准确地引用了。
Look, I'm in the volume business. That's just my metabolism. There's a big downside to that, which is nothing you do is an event. Interesting. But I just, I can't let that stop me. No, but you still make that great. Well, we'll sort that out later.
听着，我是搞批发生意的。这就是我的新陈代谢。这有一个很大的缺点，那就是你做的任何事都算不上是一个“大事件”。有趣。但我不能让这阻止我。不，但你依然把它们拍得很棒。好吧，我们待会儿再理清这个。
But I, you like doing what you do, so why not keep doing it, right? Yeah. Well, by the way, maybe it's not an event in the sense that you've, you know, if you release a film and you've released a film a year before, to the extent that like, well, okay, he's got another, but you make a, you're consistently, you make really good films. So you, that, that's not a strike against you or a knock against you. If anything, I just, I'm just interested in the process that some people like to do need that to do it more. Oh, I would love if people were like,
不过你，你喜欢做你做的事，所以为什么不继续呢，对吧？对。嗯，顺便说一句，也许它不算是一个大事件，因为你，你知道的，如果你发行了一部电影，而你前一年刚发行过一部，以至于会让人觉得，“好吧，他又有一部新片了”，但你拍的电影，你一直在稳定地产出非常优秀的电影。所以，这并不是对你的否定或打击。如果非要说的话，我只是对某些人喜欢并需要更频繁地创作的这个过程很感兴趣。哦，我倒希望大家觉得，
he's Taylor Swift. Right. He's the Taylor Swift of cinema. I would love that. Nobody is saying that. Just put a wig on. We are gonna say it. There's our tease, right there.
他就是泰勒·斯威夫特。没错。他就是电影界的泰勒·斯威夫特。我太希望这样了。没人这么说。戴个假发就行了。我们会这么说的。这就是我们的预告噱头，就在这。
Oh my God. That is our tease. Wait, I have a dumb dumb thing to say about contagion. Have people, the last 20 years just been like, did you know that when you made contagion, there was gonna be COVID? Wait, Sean, by the way, so sorry.
我的天。这就是我们的预告噱头。等等，关于《传染病》，我有一个挺蠢的问题想说。在过去20年里，大家是不是一直在说，“你知道你在拍《传染病》的时候，就会爆发新冠疫情吗？”等等，肖恩，顺便说一句，真抱歉。
How are you separating yourself from, that's what you're asking. Yeah, why do you make yourself sound like that? But where was that person from? My hub. What's your hometown, Sean? Chicago. Yeah, it was, I'll bet you did a ton of research going into that film that the past administration could have benefited from. Just your pre-production notes.
你是怎么把自己跟——这正是你想问的。对，你为什么要把自己说成那样？但那个人的口音是哪里的？我的家乡。肖恩，你的家乡在哪里？芝加哥。对，那是——我敢说你在拍那部电影时做了大量的研究，连上届政府都能从中受益。光是你的前期制作笔记就够了。
Probably gears. You know what, here we, there are a couple of things we missed. could have benefited from just your pre-production notes. Probably Gary's. You know what, here we, there are a couple of things we missed. The big one we missed was that the idea that the Jude law character in contagion would be the president. That's what we missed. We presented them, we presented them as this sort of note in a larger chord. We didn't imagine a world in which he's the chord.
可能是加里的。你知道吗，这里——我们漏掉了几件事。可能连上届政府都能从中受益。光是你的前期制作笔记就够了。可能是加里的。你知道吗，这里——我们漏掉了几件事。我们漏掉的最大一件事是，觉得《传染病》里裘德·洛这个角色会成为总统。这就是我们漏掉的。我们把他们呈现为——在更大的和弦中的某种音符。我们没有想象过这样一个世界：他本身就是那个和弦。
And so that's the big thing we got wrong. But from a technical, you want to make a comedy. No, but from a technical level, this is what everybody said. This is how it's going to start. And were you, are you a science guy, were you interested in any of that kind of stuff? Well, I mean, I like it. And-
所以这是我们搞错的最大的一件事。但从技术层面来说——你想拍喜剧。不，但从技术层面来说，这就是每个人都在说的：事情就是这样开始的。你是——你是个精通科学的人吗？你对诸如此类的事情感兴趣吗？嗯，我是说，我喜欢。然后——
The only reason I ask, cause I'm gonna ask next about magic, Mike, not that I've seen it. Well, that's science. That's science. I mean, that's your science. Sean, would you like Will and I to just take a 10 minute break? You go through all three of the magic likes.
我这么问的唯一原因，是因为我接下来要问关于《魔力麦克》的事，并不是说我看过它。好吧，那是科学。那是科学。我的意思是，那是你的科学。肖恩，你想让威尔和我休息十分钟吗？你自己把三部《魔力麦克》全讨论一遍。
Sean, and Sean's going to be embarrassed to ask you and he's kind of, he's got a bit of an issue because he went to me and said to me, I said, did you see magic? My guy said, yeah, and I said, do you like it? And he says, yeah, I was okay. I go, what's wrong? And he said, there were no fucking bears in it. And it was just slim muscle guys. I was like, I'm out.
肖恩，而且肖恩会不好意思问你，他有点——他有点纠结，因为他跑来跟我说，我问他：“你看过《魔力麦克》吗？”他说：“看过了。”我问：“你喜欢吗？”他说：“还行吧。”我问：“怎么了？”他说：“里面尼玛连一头熊都没有。”全都是精瘦的肌肉男。当时我就想：“我不看了。”
I'm out. I'm out. That's true. No, I asked about like, you know, going back to my earlier question from an hour ago, which is like, what is, what's the criteria for you to choose projects? It's like, you go from like Jason was saying,
我不看了。我不看了。确实如此。不，我是想问，你知道的，回到我一个小时前的问题，也就是：你选择项目的标准是什么？就像你从——正如杰森所说的那样，
you go from like contagionion which is a science crazy movie to remaking the ocean things or whatever the order is to strippers magic mic. I mean it's so so all over the place which is so incredible. It's so it's so yeah what's the thing that draws you to stuff is is it thematics or is it just based on well who brought me the script and who's the writer or where does it shoot is it any number of things? When I saw you directing Magic Man, I was like, Steve, what? Wait, it was so cool though. Yeah, I don't have a, I only have one rule.
你从像《传染病》这样一部满是科学元素的疯狂电影，跳到重拍《十一罗汉》之类的大片，或者不管顺序怎样，再跳到脱衣舞男电影《魔力麦克》。我的意思是，风格跨度太大了，简直太不可思议了。这太——太——是什么东西吸引你去拍这些东西的？是主题，还是仅仅取决于谁把剧本拿给我、编剧是谁、或者在哪里拍摄，是各种因素都有吗？当我看到你导演《魔力麦克》的时候，我都惊了：“史蒂夫，啥情况？”等等，不过真的很酷。对，我没有——我只有一个原则。
I don't have a rule in terms of where it comes from. It doesn't have to be my idea. I'm really agnostic about that. The only rule is if it's not a hell, yeah, it's enough. Yeah, I like that. I love that. Well, but what you say, and I mean a hell yeah, I mean, as you know, when you say, yeah, I'm going to direct this, you know what that means. And it's, it's, it's, that's rule number one. Like, it has to be a hell yeah, I would do it for free. I would do it for however long it's gonna take.
对于剧本从哪来，我没有任何原则。不一定非得是我的主意。我对这一点非常随性。唯一的原则就是，如果一个项目不是“太棒了，干吧”，那它就是个“不及格”。对，我喜欢这个。我太喜欢了。好吧，但你所说的——我是指“太棒了，干吧”，正如你所知，当你决定说“好的，我要导演这个”时，你很清楚这意味着什么。这就是第一原则。就像，它必须是一个“太棒了，干吧，哪怕不要片酬我也愿意，不管花多久时间我都愿意”。
You have to be that excited, or don't do it. Would you ever, what about if it was a hell to the years at? And let me ask you. How would, I'm a young director, I haven't done a lot, but I'm trying out this thing where the, it about you is young. It doesn't need to be a hell yeah, as much as just a yeah, because basically a double,
你必须得有这种程度的兴奋感，否则就别拍。你会不会——如果是一个“绝对不要”的项目呢？让我问你。作为一个年轻导演，我没拍过太多作品，但我正在尝试这样一种做法：关于你的剧本，它还很稚嫩。它不需要一开始就是一个“太棒了，干吧”，只要一个“行吧”就行，因为基本上，这是一个双打——
because I feel like I can make it a triple during my work with it during pre-production, and maybe even make it a home run during shooting it, and then definitely buy through post, through the editing and stuff. So, like, does it need to be like a hell yeah, at the beginning, because you've got so much time with it to make it yours?
因为我觉得在前期制作的合作过程中，我可以把它变成一个二垒安打，甚至在拍摄过程中把它变成一个本垒打，然后在后期制作、剪辑等环节中绝对能稳操胜券。所以，一开始真的需要一个“太棒了，干吧”吗？因为你有很多时间跟它相处，把它变成你自己的作品？
Well, two things. Yeah. I have the luxury of taking that position, which is not a small thing. Now, that came about through a set of circumstances that were I think pretty unique. The how sex lies happened. Yeah. Um, where some people really supported me and let me do that the way I wanted to do it. Yeah. And then from that point forward, that allowed me to do things the way I wanted them to do.
嗯，两点吧。对。我有奢侈的资本采取这种立场，这可不是件小事。而这源于一套我认为相当独特的机缘巧合。《性、谎言和录像带》是怎么拍出来的。对。当时有些人非常支持我，让我按自己想要的方式去拍。对。从那以后，这就允许我按照自己想要的方式去做事了。
I had no contractual power on sex lies. I only had the power of persuasion of convincing people. I think this is the best version of this. Yeah. They agreed. And for my sister in Wisconsin, when you say sex lies, it's sex lies and video tape, the big OV from the 90s. Do you think that's the tipping point for her?
在《性、谎言》时，我没有任何合同上的话语权。我只有说服别人的权力，去说服大家：我认为这是这个剧本最好的版本。对。他们同意了。至于我在威斯康星州的姐姐，当你提到“性、谎言”时，指的是90年代大火的《性、谎言和录像带》。你觉得这是她人生的转折点吗？
Yeah, yeah. She likes that. She likes that. Sex lies, sex lies, sex lies. But believe me, she likes to know these things. She likes to know these things. Yeah, so yeah, go ahead. Then I take your point that,
对，对。她喜欢那个。她喜欢那个。“性、谎言”、“性、谎言”、“性、谎言”。但相信我，她就喜欢了解这些。她就喜欢了解这些。对，所以，好吧，你继续。那么我接受你的观点，
depending on where you are in your life, in your career, there could be levels of hell, yeah, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah. But I feel like there's at least got to be one. Yeah. It could be the person that's the lead right in the thing. And you're like, look, there's some stuff on the edges of this that are really etched in shallow. But I love this person. I've had a great experience with this person before. I feel safe. Like, you know, that could be a hell yeah, absolutely.
根据你的人生阶段、职业生涯所处的位置，对“太棒了，干吧”可能会有不同的理解程度，你知道我的意思吗？对，对。但我觉得至少得有一个“太棒了”。比如说，可能是剧本里的某个领衔主演。你会觉得：“听着，虽然这个故事边缘的某些部分写得很表面，但我太喜欢这个人了。我以前和这个人有过非常愉快的合作经验。我感到很有安全感。”你知道的，那也可以是一个“太棒了”，绝对可以。
Can that be a crew member? Can that be a first AD or a... Yeah, I think anybody that it has to be somebody that you feel is next to you the whole time no matter how escalated any conversation gets about what this thing should be. You know what I mean? It's got to be somebody who, you're, I'm like, it's not just me, it's them too. We'll be right back. Hey smartless listener, we are brought to you in part by Macy's. The first day of school is around the corner.
那可以是一个剧组成员吗？可以是一个第一副导演吗？——对，我觉得任何人——必须是那种让你觉得无论关于这部作品的讨论升级到多激烈，他都始终站在你身边的人。你知道我的意思吗？必须是这样的人，你会觉得不仅代表你自己，也代表他们。我们马上回来。嘿，SmartLess的听众朋友们，本节目部分内容由梅西百货（Macy's）赞助播出。开学的第一天马上就要到了。
I remember those days. Exciting, but scary, but exciting. Macy's has the outfits from fave brands like Levi's, free people, and more to make picture day iconic. And of course, no first day of school is complete without a backpack and new shoes. Kipling and Nike's would make an Uber cute combo. Are the kids heading to college? Get dorm essentials like bedding.
我还记得那些日子。令人兴奋，但又有点吓人，不过还是很让人兴奋。梅西百货拥有李维斯（Levi's）、Free People等知名品牌的各种穿搭，让开学拍照日成为经典。当然，开学的第一天怎么能少得了一只新书包和一双新鞋呢？吉普林（Kipling）和耐克（Nike）的搭配绝对超级可爱。孩子们要上大学了吗？快来准备宿舍必备品，比如床上用品。
Beauty blenders for the makeup savvy and fit bits to make good use of the campus gym. I got two God kids in college, maybe I'll treat them to Macy's. In fact, I know I will. If I get some bedding for them, because God knows I don't want to go near those sheets. So head on over to Macy's.com slash back to school.
适合美妆达人的美妆蛋，还有能好好利用校园健身房的Fitbit手环。我有两个教子要上大学了，也许我会带他们去梅西百货挑选礼物。事实上，我一定会去的。如果我给他们买一些床上用品的话，因为天知道我可不想靠近他们那些床单。所以快去Macy's.com/back-to-school看看吧。
So head on over to macy's.com slash back to school. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover will improve your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed based on you and your partner's individual needs. It can cool down and warm up
所以快去macy's.com/back-to-school看看吧。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，...（背景音乐重复省略）...]在睡眠的早中期体温下降，早晨体温上升，这样你就能快速入睡并获得更多深度睡眠。Eight Sleep的Pod床垫罩就像床单一样适合任何床铺。Pod床垫罩通过根据你和伴侣的个人需求自动调节床铺两侧的温度来改善你的睡眠。它可以降温、升温，
and adjusts based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you are in. As you know, I'm in New York doing the show. I've talked about it at Nazim, and it's summertime, so it's super, super hot out. So the pod cover for me comes in handy. I need it super, super cool to counterbalance a massive heat outside.
并根据你的睡眠阶段和所处的环境进行调整。如你所知，我在纽约做节目。我在纳齐姆（Nazim）谈过这个，现在是夏天，所以外面超级、超级热。因此，Pod床垫罩对我和说非常实用。我需要它超级、超级凉爽，来抵消外面巨大的热浪。
While temperature is the biggest game changer, the pod cover has other amazing features. For example, thanks to pod sleep and health tracking, you can wake up to a personalized sleep report for you each morning that offers insights and how certain behaviors like late night exercise or caffeine or whatever impact your sleep and overall health. Invest in the rest you deserve with the 8-Sleep Pod. Go to 8thleap.com-slash-smartless and save $150 on the pod cover by 8-Sleep. That's the best offer you'll find, but you must visit 8thleep.com slash smartless for $150 off. 8th sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in
虽然温度是最大的改变者，但Pod床垫罩还有其他惊人的功能。例如，多亏了Pod的睡眠和健康追踪功能，你每天早晨都可以醒来看到一份为你量身定制的睡眠报告，其中提供了一些见解，比如深夜锻炼或咖啡因等某些行为如何影响你的睡眠和整体健康。投资于你应得的休息，选择Eight Sleep Pod。访问8sleep.com/smartless，购买Eight Sleep Pod床垫罩即可节省150美元。这是你能找到的最优惠价格，但你必须访问8sleep.com/smartless才能享受150美元的优惠。Eight Sleep目前在美国、加拿大、英国、部分欧盟国家
the EU and Australia. And back to the show. You have such an incredible eye and aesthetic and taste. And it's just, it seems like you really enjoy cinematography. It would seem to me like you would really dork out in being able to hire the most incredible cinematographers available, yet your direct photography on a lot of your own films under a different name. Well, do you sometimes want to maybe like go call Hoi Tefan Hoi Tefan and like, I mean, how do you, I don't know?
和澳大利亚发货。节目继续。你的眼光、审美和品味都太不可思议了。而且看起来你真的很享受摄影。在我看来，你本可以尽情享受能够雇佣到现今最不可思议的摄影师的乐趣，然而你在自己的很多电影中却用另一个名字亲自担任摄影。好吧，你有时会不会想去请霍伊特·范·霍伊特（Hoyte van Hoytema）来拍，我是说，你是怎么想的，我不知道？
It's a sacrifice. I'm trading one thing for another. I'm trading that I'm not as good as them for the, I'm not bad and the level of intimacy that it gives me with the cast. I would trade it even if I was bad. Yeah, yeah. I like that relationship and so it would be impossible for me to insert a genius like Emmanuel Lesky who I worked with in 1994.
这是一种牺牲。我在用一件事换另一件事。我用“我的技术不如他们”换取了“我其实也不差，而且这赋予了我与演员之间那种高度的亲密感”。哪怕我的技术很烂，我也愿意换。对，对。我很享受这种关系，所以对我来说，要插进一个像伊曼纽尔·卢贝茨基（Emmanuel Lubezki）这样的天才——我在1994年和他合作过——是不可能的。
It was his first job in the US on a anthology series for Showtime. And if you were to watch it now, it's all there. He was fully formed. He was Chivo right out of the gate, but I really need that. I need that sense of just us in the room. Right. It takes away a late one, once you put another person in there, and again, these are brilliant people. You feel like it removes a, it just puts yet another barrier between you and the cast in that way that you've got to constantly run You you there's a there's an added layer of dialogue that you have to have With some other person rather than it just being you in the camera and the cast and working Right? Yeah, and it's it's not like I'm saying ever that should be everybody's goal
那是他在美国的第一份工作，是为Showtime电视台拍的一部诗选剧。如果你现在去看那部剧，所有的东西都在那儿了。他当时就已经完全成熟了。他一出道就是Chivo（卢贝茨基的昵称），但我真的很需要那种感觉。我需要那种“房间里只有我们俩”的感觉。没错。一旦你把另一个人放进来，这种感觉就被打破了，再说一次，这些人都是天才。你会觉得这移除了一个——这等于在你和演员之间又筑起了一道屏障，你必须不断地去奔波——
No, I'm just I'm just saying like you this is how I came up I I was hanging out for four years of high school with these college aspiring filmmakers. I knew my way around a dark room. I was a photographer for the yearbook. Like it it it just was a very organic thing to want to be the nodal point for a series of decisions that constitute directing, like that was, and it just took me a while to work my way back to that. But I feel like you make really sort of sophisticated films and you don't, and you have a lot of,
你——你——你必须和另一个人进行额外一层的对话，而不是只有你、摄像机和演员在现场工作。对吧？对，这并不是说我认为这应该成为所有人的目标。
you sort of trust that the audience can meet you there. That's one of the things that I really enjoy about your films. I feel like they're like accessible sophisticated films. And you're not worried about alienating your, the audience. In fact, I imagine that you have, and tell me if I'm wrong, but that you've had conversations with studios over the years where they've been worried that your films are thematically or the way that they look or the way that they set up or that they're worried that it's not going to connect with the audience and that I get this feeling from you that it's like, it's okay. I know what I'm doing. I'm going to make this film. Yes, it's going to have a sophisticated
不，我只是说——这就是我的成长经历。我在高中四年里一直和那些立志成为电影制作人的大学年轻人厮混在一起。我懂得怎么用暗房。我是年鉴的摄影师。所以——想要成为构成导演工作的一系列决策的中心节点，这是一件非常自然的事情，当时就是这样，我花了好一阵子才重新回到这种状态。但我感觉你拍的电影都非常富有深度，而且你没有——你非常信任观众能够跟上你的节奏。这是我非常喜欢你的电影的特点之一。我觉得它们是那种平易近人的深度电影。你并不担心会疏离观众。事实上，我猜想——如果你说得不对请纠正我——多年来你和制片厂开会时，他们曾担心过你的电影在主题上、视觉呈现上、或者镜头设置上无法与观众产生共鸣，而我从你身上感受到的态度是：“没关系。我知道我在做什么。我要拍这部电影。没错，它会有深刻的
elements to it, but I'm going to connect with the audience. It does seem like you're always aware that there's a big commercial center of it that you are giving something to the audience to the studio, but the execution is always elevated and sophisticated. Well, the films that I like the most were both commercial and artful. I mean, that was what the American New Wave did. It fused a sort of aesthetic that came from outside of the United States of America, a sort of aesthetic that came from outside of the United States of America, a sort of attention to style and character that people in other parts of the world were doing.
元素，但我会与观众产生共鸣。”看起来你似乎总是意识到其中有一个庞大的商业核心，你在向观众和制片厂提供某种东西，但影片的呈现方式总是被提升到一个更高的、更有深度的水平。好吧，我最喜欢的电影既有商业性，又极具艺术感。我的意思是，那正是美国新浪潮电影所做的事。它融合了一种源自美利坚合众国之外的审美，一种源自美利坚合众国之外的审美，一种对风格和人物的关注，而世界上其他地方的人们也正在这样做。
And then blended it with this very, very American desire to tell a clear narrative. And that it was like the perfect fusion of these two. That's what I wanted to do. So, you know, the things that I feel haven't worked have been the ones that have fallen too far into, wow, that would really work if it had subtitles. But can you explain style to Jason and Sean because they, I don't know how to say lack of it,
然后把它与这种非常、非常美国式的、想要讲述一个清晰故事的愿望融合在一起。这就好像是这两者的完美融合。这正是我想要做的。所以，你知道的，我觉得那些失败的作品，往往是那些过于陷入“哇，如果有字幕的话，这个桥段肯定超级带感”的电影。但是，你能向杰森和肖恩解释一下什么是风格吗？因为他们——我不知道该怎么说他们缺乏这种东西，
it's just that they're on a smart list. You should on. Oh, there it is. There it is. Well, you did mention that all the presidents men is one of your favorite movies. What's your favorite film of all time? Well, that's impossible. But I think you rank you rank them at one point and all the presidents men was number two. I was very excited. Yeah, when I was younger, I used to. But I think, look, in the summer of 1975, when I was in St. Petersburg, Florida visiting my grandparents
只是他们正在做一档叫SmartLess的节目。你应该的。哦，来了，来了。好吧，你确实提到过《总统班底》是你最喜欢的电影之一。你历来最喜欢的电影是什么？嗯，那不可能挑出来。但我觉得你曾在某个时候给它们排过名，《总统班底》排在第二位。我当时兴奋极了。对，我年轻的时候，我曾经。但我觉得，听吧，在1975年的夏天，当我在圣彼得堡——佛罗里达州独自看望祖父母时，
alone, I saw jobs. Now, I was just gonna bring that up. Prior to this point, my father was a cinema fanatic. He gave me the cinema bug and we watched. He took me to the web like we all, this was part of our bond. Right, so. But that was the first time after that movie was over. Ironically, this perfect piece of entertainment now made me not think of movies as just entertainment
我看了《大白鲨》。我正想提这个呢。在此之前，我父亲是个狂热的影迷。是他带我入了电影的坑，我们一起看。他带我去——就像我们所有人一样，这是我们父子纽带的一部分。没错，所以。但那是那部电影结束后，我第一次——具有讽刺意味的是，这个如今堪称完美的娱乐大片，却让我不再把电影仅仅当作娱乐了。
anymore. So I had two questions. What is directed by me and who is Steven Spielberg? So it turns out, you know, in any store that you walked into, there was a paperback called the JAWSLog that Carl Gottlieb wrote, and it answered both of those questions. And I carried this thing around with me and highlighted every section that mentioned Steven Spielberg. And then a year later,
所以我当时有两个问题：导演是谁？史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格又是谁？结果证明，你知道的，在你走进的任何一家书店里，都有一本卡尔·戈特利布（Carl Gottlieb）写的平装书叫《大白鲨手记》（The Jaws Log），它解答了这两个问题。我把这本书带在身边，用荧光笔把每一个提到史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格的段落都高亮出来了。然后一年后，
when we moved to Baton Rouge, Louisiana, where my dad was dean of education at LSU, I fell in with these college film students and got my hands on a camera and everything started to move. Wow. And if you say both of your names fast, they sound the same. Oh, I was just going to say, when you were saying, talking about like, you know, Americanizing storytelling, I was literally, I swear to God, I was going to say like, Jaws, I was going
当我们搬到路易斯安那州巴吞鲁日市时——我父亲在那里担任路易斯安那州立大学（LSU）的教育学院院长——我和这群大学电影系学生混在了一起，弄到了一台摄像机，一切开始运转了。哇。如果你把你们俩的名字连起来快速念，听起来是一样的。哦，我正要说呢，当你刚才说——谈到诸如此类的事情，关于美国式的讲故事方式时，我当时真的——我发誓，我本来想说《大白鲨》的，我本来想说那个的。不过话说回来，你现在还去电影院看电影吗？还是只在家里看？
to say that. But anyway, do you still go to the movie theaters now or do you just watch that? I'll be thinking at home. No, I do both. I do, yeah. I still, this is never gonna go away. It's too fun to see something with a lot of people.
不，两样都做。我会的，对。我依然——这种习惯永远不会消失。和很多人一起看电影实在是太有趣了。
Have you seen something about the movie theaters that you love recently? I think the last thing I saw in a theater, and this is only because I've shot three things in a row in the last 12 months. Last thing I saw in a theater would have been Top Gun, which just proves that Tom Cruise has saved the movie that something had been made.
最近有什么在电影院看的让你觉得很棒的东西吗？我想我在电影院看的最后一部作品——这纯粹是因为我在过去12个月里连续拍了三部作品——我在电影院看的最后一部应该是《壮志凌云：独行侠》，这刚好证明了汤姆·克鲁斯拯救了电影院，拯救了某种曾经被拍摄出来的东西。
Right, right? Now, I wanna talk about full circle, but before we do, we, oh, first thing that comes to your mind if I ask you what your favorite part of directing is. The surprise that is the result of arranging the elements in the right way that will result in a surprise, something, typically something an actor does. And where do you see that surprise?
没错，对吧？现在，我想聊聊《全景阴谋》（Full Circle），但在我们开始之前，我们——哦，如果我问你导演工作你最喜欢的部分是什么，你脑海中浮现的第一件事是什么？那种通过以正确的方式排列各种元素从而带来惊喜的奇妙体验，通常是演员带来的某种表现。你会在哪里看到这种惊喜？
Do you see it on the first rehearsal? Do you see it on the first take? Or do you see it when you put it all together in the editing room? I'm open to any of that. If it happens in a rehearsal, it's, as long as it happens, we win. So you're open and excited to that which you did
你是在第一次排练时看到？还是在第一次试拍时看到？抑或是当你把所有东西在剪辑室里拼凑到一起时看到？我都行。如果它发生在排练中，那——只要它能发生，我们就赢了。所以你对那种你从未
to imagine life's fate. There was a thing that a shot that we did in Logan Lucky where Adam Deriver or something's shot out of a tube to Adam and there's there's some lack of understanding whether the thing that's in his hand could actually blow up and kill all of them. And Daniel Craig is sort of, yeah. He comes over and takes the thing from Adam and had a reaction on the first tape that I ruined the tape. Too much laughing.
想象过的人生巧合持开放和兴奋的态度。我们在拍《幸运洛根》时有一个镜头，亚当·德赖弗（Adam Driver）或某个角色从管道里向亚当开枪，大家对于他手里的东西是否真的会爆炸并炸死所有人有点吃不准。而丹尼尔·克雷格大概是——对。他走过去从亚当手里拿过那个东西，在第一次试拍时的反应直接把那条给毁了。笑得太厉害了。
No, I just ruined the tape. Like it was something I didn't see coming. And it's in the movie, but I had to loop his vocalization just before he did it and his vocalization just after because he was laughing. Yeah. But what about have you what was the camera shaking till? Because you were no thank God. It was on a head. It was locked down. So I was touching it, but I didn't shake it.
不，我只是把那条毁了。那是我始料未及的。虽然它被剪进电影里了，但我不得不把他在那之前发出的声音和在那之后发出的声音做成循环音轨，因为他在笑。对吧？但是——相机有没有因为你在笑而晃动？因为你当时在——没有，谢天谢地。它装在云台上。是锁定的。所以我当时碰了它，但我没有晃动它。
And that's a problem as you know, they can be solved and posed. But no, that means we all did our job and created this sort of velvet lined shoot that led to somebody going, what if I did this? And you're like, that's better. It's better. How worried are you about AI?
正如你所知，那是个问题，但可以在后期解决。不，这意味着我们都做好了自己的工作，创造了一种天鹅绒般顺滑的拍摄过程，最终引得某个人说：“如果我这么做怎么样？”而你会说：“那样更好。更好。”你对人工智能有多担心？
Well, that's a good question. Not just for filmmaking, just in general, because I feel that's a good question, because I think this is at the center of a lot of what's going on right now. I can only speak of it as a creative person and go, it's an iterative tool. It's never gonna get you in the end zone.
嗯，这是个好问题。不仅是针对电影制作，就大环境而言，因为我觉得——这是个好问题，因为我认为这正是目前许多事情的核心所在。我只能以一个创意人的身份来谈论它，并认为：它只是一个迭代工具。它永远无法带你冲过终点线。
It hasn't experienced anything. It's, you know what I mean? Like, it hasn't experienced anything. Even to the point of, it can look into your eyes, but it has no eyes. And so therefore, it doesn't know what it means, you know, to be looked at by some like my mom, right? That's what I was saying.
因为它没有经历过任何事情。你知道我的意思吗？它没有经历过任何事情。甚至从某种程度来说，它可以直视你的双眼，但它并没有眼睛。因此，它并不懂得被某个人——比如我妈妈——注视着意味着什么，对吧？这就是我想说的。
And I think what you're describing potentially is what I've just sort of blank it and use the blanket term of quirk. It doesn't have the advantage of possessing any quirk because it hasn't had any experience. Nothing's happened to it. But Jason, I think to your point, to me, it's just an iterative tool. There's that perfect explanation of how to solve things from the Ed Katmull book about Pixar or Creativity Inc. Where the motto is, be wrong as fast as you can. So, this is a tool, this is a tool to just, what I tell people all the time is, just get
我想你所描述的，可能就是我简称为“怪癖（quirk）”的那个概念。它不具备拥有任何怪癖的优势，因为它没有任何经历。什么都没在它身上发生过。但杰森，说到你的观点，对我来说，它只是一个迭代工具。皮克斯的埃德·卡特穆尔（Ed Catmull）的书《创意公司》（Creativity Inc.）里有一个关于如何解决问题的完美解释，其座右铭是：以最快的速度出错。所以，这是一个工具，这是一个工具，我经常对人们说的是：只要能
to the end. If this helps people get to the end, does something fine? All right. Tell us about full circle. And I watched the first episode. It is typically and predictably fantastic. Another piece of great work from you. It's by design somewhat cryptic at the beginning, and I'm imagining the future episodes, things
到达终点就行。如果这能帮助人们到达终点，做出好东西，那又有什么关系呢？好了。给我们讲讲《全景阴谋》吧。我看了第一集。它一如既往、不出意料地精彩。又是你的一部杰作。它在一开始带有某种设计上的神秘感，我猜在接下来的剧集中，事情会
start to slot into place. So without giving away any of those satisfying things, what is the thing? It is a kidnapping that goes wrong. But is there a thematic there at work that you like to play with often or not? Oh, sure. I mean, you know, buried things never stay buried. I mean, that's what this is about. And in this instance, you know, it'd been buried for long enough that people had literally
开始各就各位。所以，在不剧透那些让人大呼过瘾的内容的前提下，这究竟是个什么样的故事？这是一起搞砸了的绑架案。但其中是否有你经常喜欢探讨的主题在起作用呢？哦，当然。我是说，你知道的，被埋葬的事情永远不会真正被埋葬。这就是这个故事的主旨。而在这种情况下，你知道的，这件事情已经被埋葬得够久了，以至于人们几乎
forgotten about it. And so it's kind of a rude awakening. You can run, but you can't hide, can't you? Yeah. And it's absolutely privileged, torture porn. I'm a big fan of that genre. I think I think Ed Solomon, I think Ed Solomon found a really interesting take on that. And so, you know, I love that non-linear storytelling and different perspectives. I can't wait to be surprised how they come together and
把它给忘了。所以这有点像是一次当头棒喝。你能跑得了和尚，跑不了庙，对吧？对。而且这绝对是特权阶级的虐心爽剧。我是那个类型的超级粉丝。我认为——我认为埃德·所罗门（Ed Solomon）对这个题材找到了一个非常有趣的切入点。所以，你知道的，我非常喜欢这种非线性叙事和多重视角。我等不及想看看它们是如何汇聚在一起，并在
braid at some point. Well, for a while. I don't know to be surprised. They come together and braid at some point. Well, first of all, you do that so well. I don't know anything about it, Stephen. And I'm a big kind of Ed Salman. I've actually wrote Bill and Ted's and Men in Bite. Another guy is very prolific and done a lot of stuff. It's very thematically different from the next one. And a bunch of the next.
某个时刻交织成辫的，这让我感到惊喜。好吧，有一段时间。我不知道会这么惊喜。它们在某个时刻汇聚并交织成辫。首先，你把这一点做得太棒了。我对这个一无所知，史蒂芬。而且我非常欣赏埃德·所罗门，他实际上写过《比尔和泰德历险记》和《黑衣人》。他是另一个非常高产、拍过很多作品的家伙。他的作品主题与下一部截然不同。而且有很多作品都是跟——
And a bunch of stuff with you, which is such a great pairing now that I think about it. Of course, you guys are both just clearly interested, not interesting people. I'm sure you're both very interesting as well, but you're also very interested, which is great. What is full circle? Because I know nothing about it.
而且有很多作品都是跟你合作的，现在想来这真是一个绝佳的组合。当然，你们俩显然都很感兴趣，不是说你们是有趣的人——我确信你们两个也绝对非常有趣，但你们同样也对世界充满好奇，这太棒了。《全景阴谋》到底是什么？因为我对它一无所知。
It's a show that's coming on Max. Yeah, it's a gigantic sort of New York Sydney Lumet style melodrama. You know what I mean? There's a crime in the center of it that sort of takes you all over the city. And like I said, it's about karma. It's about something that somebody took a party 20 years ago, forgot about it, and now it's come back. It's grown roots and branches, and now they have to deal with it. And that's the kind of
这是一部将在Max上播出的剧集。对，这是一部宏大的、西德尼·吕美特（Sydney Lumet）风格的纽约式情节剧。你知道我的意思吗？它的核心是一起犯罪，把整个城市都牵扯进来了。就像我说的，这是关于因果报应的。这是关于2020年前某个人曾参与其中、后来却忘得精光的一件事，如今它卷土重来。它已经生根发芽、枝繁叶茂，现在他们不得不去面对它。而这正是我喜欢的那种
thing that I like. It was fun to make a real New York, you know what I mean? Like, It's fun to make a real New York. Yeah. You know what I mean? It seemed like there's a lot of night work in that, Steven. There was a lot of night work. And if I were the studios, if I were the studios negotiating, I would give up almost everything to say like 5%, like night work, Yeah, more than that. We're just hated. Yeah. Now, a little talk about side bars. Side job here for you. A
东西。能拍一部地地道道的纽约剧真的很有趣，你知道我的意思吗？拍一部地地道道的纽约剧真的很有趣。对。你知道我的意思吗？看起来里面有很多夜戏，史蒂芬。确实有很多夜戏。如果我是制片厂的话，如果我是参与谈判的制片厂，我会放弃几乎所有的条件，只要能说定像“5%的夜戏”——对，比那更多。我们简直恨透了夜戏。对。现在，聊聊插话的事。这里有个你的副业。一个
Signani 63 is a beverage. Are you getting into the, to the, what's Signani? Oh God, you guys. The business a little bit. Yeah. Sengani is a spirit from Bolivia. It's just booze, guys. It's booze. It's hard stuff. Anyway, I'm going to do this really quickly when we were making Che, our Bolivian casting director gave me a bottle. As a gift, it had never been out of Bolivia. It's the National Spirit of Bolivia. And it's made from the white musk out of Alexandria.
塞甘尼（Singani 63）酒类品牌。你这是要进军——进军什么叫塞甘尼？哦天哪，你们这帮人。进军酒水行业了吗？对。塞甘尼是一种来自玻利维亚的烈酒。这只是酒，伙计们。这就是酒。是烈性酒。不管怎样，我很快地说一下，当年我们在拍《切·格瓦拉》时，我们的玻利维亚选角导演送了我一瓶。作为礼物，它以前从来没有离开过玻利维亚。它是玻利维亚的国酒。它是用亚历山大的白麝香葡萄酿造的。
Great. It was a white grape. It's grown into steel. And there's one 20,000 acre area of southern Bolivia. It's 6,000 feet. So it's a very, very, it's hard to make. And I got this stuff stuff and I loved it. And for the next six months, while we were shooting, I created a mule train so that we could all drink it.
太棒了。那是一种白葡萄。它是在钢制容器中酿造的。而且只产于玻利维亚南部一个两万英亩的地区。海拔有6000英尺。所以非常、非常——很难酿造。我得到了这个酒，并且爱上了它。在接下来的六个月拍摄期间，我组建了一支骡队，好让我们所有人都能喝上它。
At the end of that, some people pressured me to bring this to America, which I did in 2014. In February of this year, the Tax and Terror Bureau, which is part of the Treasury Department and FDA and ATF, gave St. Garni its own category. This is something they don't do often. It's something they don't like to do, but they did it because it's a unique spirit. And this solved one problem when I was doing my Willie Lomon act, taking bottles around in a backpack and going, hey, what do you think?
在那之后，有些人向我施压，让我把这东西带到美国来，我在2014年这么做了。今年2月，隶属于财政部、食品药品监督管理局（FDA）和烟酒枪炮及爆炸物管理局（ATF）的税收与贸易局（TTB）给塞甘尼授予了它专属的酒类类别。这是他们不常做的事。这是他们不喜欢做的事，但他们这么做了，因为它是一种独特的烈酒。这解决了我之前扮演威利·洛曼（Willy Loman）式的推销员时遇到的一个问题——背着背包到处送酒瓶，然后说：“嘿，你觉得这个怎么样？”
Not a great look. Now, if legitimize is that, when people will go, well, what is it like? And I would go, well, it's not actually like anything. And now, finally, that's been legitimized. But let's just end with, do not go into the booze business. Don't do it. Well, there's no a cluny set.
这形象可不太好。现在，如果这合法化了，当人们问：“嗯，这喝起来像什么？”时，我就会回答：“嗯，其实它什么都不像。”现在，终于，这获得官方认可了。但让我们以这句话结尾：千万别进军酒水行业。千万别做这个。好吧，除非你是乔治·克鲁尼。
Yeah, or Ryan Reynolds. Don't know. He knows how angry I am. I've told him. It's funny, because I did some, it was quite more profit, some muleing out of Bolivia myself, but it was a different. Um, Jesus. I know. Stephen, it's such an honor to meet you.
对，或者瑞安·雷诺兹。不知道。他知道我有多生气。我跟他说过。这挺有意思的，因为我自己也从玻利维亚走私、用骡子运过一些酒，不过是另一种。天哪。我知道。史蒂芬，能见到你真是太荣幸了。
I've wanted to meet you forever and I'm being, I think, saying it. You're kind of all your movies. We, uh, we so appreciate you, uh, you spending some time with us. Sure do. So happy to meet you, finally. I'm going to hook up to this at the same time next week if you guys are here. Yeah, surely. Yeah, I totally will. Sadly, we'll this at the same time next week if you guys are here. Yeah, truly. Yeah, it's hard to say.
我一直想见你，而且我想说——你所有的电影。我们——我们非常感激你花时间跟我们聊天。确实如此。很高兴终于见到你了。如果你们都在这的话，下周这个时候我会继续连线的。对，真的。对，我绝对会的。遗憾的是，我们下周这个时候
Sadly, we'll be in the same scene. I want to see you cascade down that staircase. Yeah. Yeah. Thank you so much. Thank you very much. Thank you very much. Can't wait to meet you'll person one day
还在同一个片场。我想看你从那个楼梯上跌落下来。对。对。非常感谢。非常感谢。非常感谢。迫不及待地想有一天能亲自见到你，
and have a great rest of your day, Stephen. Thank you for coming. Thanks. Thank you, pal. All right, bye, pal. There you have, Stephen Soderbergh. It was a nice surprise, Jason, baby, man. This man, how'd you get that?
祝你今天剩下的时间过得愉快，史蒂芬。谢谢你的到来。谢谢。谢谢你，老兄。好吧，再见，老兄。以上就是史蒂芬·索德伯格。这真是个惊喜，杰森，宝贝，伙计。这人，你是怎么请到的？
Yeah. I don't, you know, I've got my ways. No, I don't tell us, but okay. My God, I am very surprised I've never, have you guys ever run into him? No, never. Never. Never. Never. Never not one. He's not a man about town. I don't know.
对。我不知道，你知道的，我有我的办法。不，别告诉我们，不过好吧。天哪，我太惊讶了，我从来没——你们以前从来没遇到过他吗？从没有。从没有。从没有。一次都没有。他可不是那种爱在社交场合抛头露面的花花公子。我不知道。
And I will say, I meant to do, I really admire how prolific he's been. I love the idea that he just takes so many, not just a lot of shots, so many different kinds of shots. Like Aaron Brockovich. Aaron Brockovich. And then... Sex, magic, video tape, traffic. Just like magic, my, all those things, all by the same guy.
我要说的是，我真的很佩服他一直以来惊人的产量。我喜欢这种他不仅尝试大量拍摄，而且尝试拍摄各种不同类型电影的做法。比如《永不妥协》。《永不妥协》。还有……《性、谎言、录像带》、《毒网》。就像变魔术一样，天哪，所有这些作品，竟然都出自同一个人之手。
But what about that? Not since 1938 or 39, I think it was, had a director been nominated for two films in the same year. For Bestor. You nominated for Aaron Brockovich and Traffic. Traffic Best Director.
但话又说回来，你知道吗？自1938年或1939年以来，好像就再也没有哪个导演在同一年凭两部电影获得最佳导演提名了。你同时凭《永不妥协》和《毒网》获得了提名。《毒网》的最佳导演。
And so we had two slots in the file. That's incredible. That's bananas. That is bananas. It is bananas. How quickly Sean, did you go, um, do you opening data full frontal? When that came out, that was the next year. That was the next year. He did full frontal. I preordered tickets for that. Yeah. Yeah. Hey, by the way, you know what, I just learned
所以我们占了两个名额。这太不可思议了。简直太疯狂了。太疯狂了。确实太疯狂了。肖恩，你是什么时候开始着手拍《正面全裸》的？那可是第二年上映的。那是第二年。他拍了《正面全裸》。我还为那部电影预订了票。对，对。对了，你们知道吗，我昨天刚刚听说
yesterday, guys? Tell Sean, this should be good. And Hawaii. Uh-huh. Did you know? It's against the blind apples and no, No, no, no, no. Why? No, listen to the whole thing. And why? It's against the law to laugh really hard out loud in public. Did you know that? That's a bullshit. You have to keep it to a low, huh?
伙计们？告诉肖恩，这应该挺有意思的。在夏威夷。嗯哼。你知道吗？法律规定——苹果？不是，不是，不是，不是。为什么？不，听我把话说完。在夏威夷。法律规定在公共场合大声狂笑是违法的。你知道吗？这简直是胡扯。你只能小声笑，是吧？
Oh, man. I would just also like to say. Fuck. Man. I would just also like to say. Oh. Oh. Oh. So I also like to say. I would also like to say, I love when I see you guys, because we don't see each other, and whenever we get together, we talk for a really long time. You know, it's like time flies by.
天哪。我还想说。操。天哪。我还想说。哦。哦。哦。所以我也想说。我还想说，我很高兴见到你们，因为我们平时不常见面，每当聚在一起，我们总会聊很久。你知道的，感觉时光飞逝。
Oh, will to not like that one. They're just getting lazier. You're just kind of. Time flies by is a good one. Shooting in a father joke too. A dad joke. I just heard it yesterday. That's really good.
哦，别嫌弃这个。他们只是越来越懒了。你这纯粹是……“时光飞逝”倒是个不错的梗。还顺便夹带了一个冷笑话。一个老爸笑话。我昨天刚听说的。真的挺不错的。
His signature is just a bad joke. And then he tries to shoehorn in a bite. It's so... That was a good one. We've never used time flies by. No. Smarks. Smarks.
他的标志就是讲个烂笑话。然后还硬要塞进去一个痛点。真是……刚才那个不错。“时光飞逝”我们以前从没用过。没有。懂行的人。懂行的人。
Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smarks. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armstrong, and Bennett Barberco.
懂行的人。懂行的人。懂行的人。懂行的人。懂行的人。懂行的人。《Smartless》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆斯特朗和贝内特·巴尔贝科100%有机且手工打造。
This episode was recorded on May 30th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Casey Shane was murdered in the middle of an August night, shot Point Blank, while idling in his Dodge pickup truck in North Indianapolis. There was no physical evidence, no known motive, and no one coming forward with information, except one woman who swears to this day she saw Leon to Troi Benson pull the trigger.
本期节目于5月30日录制。我们的下一期节目将在两周内发布，你可以在各大播客平台收听，也可以现在就在Amazon Music上抢先收听，或者通过Apple Podcasts上的Wondry Plus或Wondry应用订阅，享受抢先收听和无广告的特权。凯西·谢恩在一个八月的深夜被谋杀，在印第安纳州北部，他驾驶着道奇皮卡车在 idling 时被近距离枪击。现场没有任何物证，没有已知的作案动机，也没有人站出来提供线索，只有一个女人发誓，直到今天她依然坚信自己看到莱昂·德特洛伊·本森扣动了扳机。
Leon Benson was sentenced to 60 years in prison, all because one person swore they saw something. But what if she was wrong, And what if we could prove it? From Wondery and Campside Media, comes season three of the Hit Podcast Suspect, co-hosted by me, Matt Cher, alongside Attorney Laura Baselon. This is a story of a botched police investigation, the dangers of shaky eyewitness testimony, and a community of feared law enforcement.
莱昂·本森被判处60年监禁，仅仅因为一个人发誓她看到了什么。但如果她看错了呢？如果我们能证明这一点呢？由Wondery和Campside Media联合制作的热门播客《嫌疑人》第三季来了，由我，马特·谢尔，以及律师劳拉·巴塞尔隆共同主持。这是一个关于拙劣的警方调查、不可靠的目击证词的危险，以及一个令人生畏的执法社区的故事。
With good reason. Listen to Suspect, five shots in the dark, wherever you get your podcasts, or binge all eight episodes, add free on Wondery Plus. Find Wondery Plus in the Wondery app, or on Apple Podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有充分的理由。请在各大播客平台收听《嫌疑人：黑暗中的五枪》，或者在Wondery Plus上无广告畅听全部八集。在Wondery应用或Apple Podcasts上查找Wondery Plus。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。